>>> FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP
THROWING HIS WEIGHT BEHIND
HUNGARY'S AUTHORITARIAN LEADER
WITH A RINGING ENDORSEMENT.
YESTERDAY, TRUMP MADE THIS
STATEMENT.
QUOTE, VICTOR OBAN OF HUNGARY
TRULY LOVES HIS COUNTRY AND
WANTS SAFETY FOR HIS PEOPLE.
HE'S DONE A POWERFUL AND
WONDERFUL JOB IN STOPPING
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION, PROMOTING
TRADE, AND SHOULD CONTINUE TO DO
SO IN THE UPCOMING ELECTION.
HE IS A STRONG LEADER AND
RESPECTED BY ALL.
HE HAS MY COMPLETE SUPPORT AND
ENDORSEMENT FOR RE-ELECTION AS
PRIME MINISTER.
ORBAN HAS SHIFTED HUNGARY TOWARD
AUTOCRACY IN THE LAST DECADE.
HE'S ATTACKED THE RIGHTS OF
JOURNALISTS AND DOUBLED DOWN ON
THE GOVERNMENT'S CONTROL OF
MEDIA.
FOR ALL OF THOSE ANTI-AMERICAN
MOVES, HE HAS BEEN REWARDED WITH
QUITE THE FOLLOWING IN PRO-TRUMP
CIRCLES.
>> HERE'S VICTOR ORBAN.
HIS ACCENT IS THICK, BUT HIS
ENGLISH IS PRECISE.
HE IS WORTH HEARING.
>> ORBAN IS NOT SPECIAL.
HE IS JUST THE LATEST STRONGMAN
FLAVOR OF THE WEEK RECEIVING
TRUMP'S AFFECTIONS.
AS TRUMP HAS MADE CLEAR THAT HE,
HIMSELF, WOULD PREFER TO BE A
STRONGMAN RATHER THAN A
DEMOCRATICALLY-ELECTED PRESIDENT
AT THE HELM OF A CO-EQUAL BRANCH
OF GOVERNMENT THAT IS THE
FOUNDATION OF THE AMERICAN
EXPERIMENT.
IF THIS WERE A ROSE CEREMONY ON
THE "BACHELOR" ORBAN WOULD BE
JUST A FACE IN THE CROWD, IN
COMPETITION WITH A LITANY OF
OTHER DESPOTS, LIKE VLADIMIR
PUTIN, WHOM TRUMP HAS BEEN
PARTICULARLY SMITTEN.
>> PUTIN IS A KILLER.
>> A LOT OF KILLERS, GET A LOT
OF KILLERS.
YOU THINK OUR COUNTRY IS SO
INNOCENT?
>> I DON'T KNOW OF ANY
GOVERNMENT LEADERS THAT ARE
KILLERS IN AMERICA.
>> WELL, TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT
WE'VE DONE, TOO.
WE'VE MADE A LOT OF MISTAKES.
I WAS AGAINST THE WAR IN IRAQ
FROM THE BEGINNING.
>> BEING A KILLER NORMALLY
DISQUALIFYING FOR A LOVE MATCH,
BUT NOT FOR TRUMP.
WHEN IT COMES TO PUTIN OR THE
LEADER OF CHINA.
>> YOU KNOW, I HAD A GREAT
RELATIONSHIP WITH PRESIDENT XI.
I REALLY BELIEVE HE LIKED ME AND
I LIKED HIM.
>> HE'S A KILLER.
>> I HAD A -- HE IS A KILLER,
BUT I HAD A GREAT RELATIONSHIP
WITH HIM.
>> THE BLESSED ARRANGEMENT, THAT
DREAM WITHIN A DREAM, BECAUSE A
MARRIAGE BETWEEN RUSSIA AND
CHINA AND THE U.S. SHOULD BE AS
DESTINED TO SUCCEED AS ONE
BETWEEN HUMPERDINK AND PRINCESS
BUTTERCUP, FOR "THE PRINCESS
BRIDE."
HE HAS ONE OF THE WORST RECORDS
ON HUMAN RIGHTS IN THE WORLD.
TRUMP IS NOT ONE TO LET THAT GET
IN THE WAY OF A RELATIONSHIP.
CERTAINLY NOT WITH TURKEY'S
STRONGMAN.
>> HAD A VERY GOOD CONVERSATION
WITH PRESIDENT ERDOGAN.
I RESPECT HIM.
WE HAVE A VERY GOOD
RELATIONSHIP.
YES, I AGREE, HE IS A TOUGH GUY,
BUT WE HAVE A VERY GOOD
RELATIONSHIP.
I SEEM TO DO BETTER WITH TOUGH
PEOPLE.
>> TRUMP ALSO ENJOYS THE COMPANY
OF A GUY WHO OVERTHREW HIS
NATION'S FIRST DEMOCRATICALLY
ELECTED GOVERNMENT, THE
PRESIDENT OF EGYPT.
>> I WILL TELL YOU, PRESIDENTAL
SISI HAS BEEN CLOSE TO ME, FROM
THE FIRST TIME I MET HIM.
I MET DURING THE CAMPAIGN.
AT THAT POINT, THERE WERE TWO OF
US.
WE BOTH MET.
HOPEFULLY YOU LIKED ME A LOT
MORE.
BUT IT WAS A VERY LONG -- IT WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE A QUICK, BRIEF
MEETING, AND WE WERE WITH EACH
OTHER FOR A LONG PERIOD OF TIME.
WE AGREE ON SO MANY THINGS.
I JUST WANT TO LET EVERYBODY
KNOW, IN CASE THERE WAS ANY
DOUBT, THAT WE ARE VERY MUCH
BEHIND PRESIDENT EL SISI.
HE'S DONE A GREAT JOB.
>> COLD-BLOODED MURDER?
THAT'S NOT ONE TRUMP WILL LET
INTERRUPT AFFAIRS OF THE HEART.
>> A FRIEND OF MINE, A MAN WHO
HAS REALLY DONE THINGS IN THE
LAST FIVE YEARS IN TERMS OF
OPENING UP SAUDI ARABIA.
I WANT TO JUST THANK YOU ON
BEHALF OF A LOT OF PEOPLE.
I WANT TO CONGRATULATE YOU.
YOU'VE DONE REALLY A SPECTACULAR
JOB.
>> VERY EARLY ON IN HIS
PRESIDENCY, TRUMP CONGRATULATED
HIS COUNTERPART IN THE
PHILIPPINES, DESPITE RODRIGO
DUTERTE GREEN LIGHTING
EXTRAJUDICIAL KILLINGS IN THE
NAME OF FIGHTING DRUGS,
RESULTING IN THOUSANDS OF BESTO
THE TRUMP OF BRAZIL.
>> TODAY, I'M VERY THRILLED TO
WELCOME PRESIDENT BALSANARO OF
BRAZIL FOR HIS FIRST VISIT TO
THE WHITE HOUSE.
I WANT TO CONGRATULATE YOU AGAIN
ON YOUR TREMENDOUS ELECTION
VICTORY.
LAST OCTOBER, IT WAS AN
INCREDIBLE FEAT.
REALLY, A TRULY INCREDIBLE
CHALLENGE, AND THE END RESULT
WAS SOMETHING THE WHOLE WORLD
WAS TALKING ABOUT.
ALSO KNOW WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A
FANTASTIC WORKING RELATIONSHIP.
WE HAVE MANY VIEWS THAT ARE
SIMILAR.
>> SIMILAR.
KINDRED EVEN.
BALSANARO HAS DOWNPLAYED THE
PANDEMIC, UNNECESSARILY COSTING
THE LIVES OF HIS COUNTRYMEN.
YET, HE IS STILL NOT THE ONE.
NO, THAT WOULD BE NORTH KOREA'S
DICTATOR.
AS SINEAD O'CONNOR MIGHT SAY,
NOTHING COMPARES TO YOU.
>> HE WROTE ME BEAUTIFUL
LETTERS, AND THEY'RE GREAT
LETTERS.
WE FELL IN LOVE.
HEY, HE'S THE HEAD OF A COUNTRY.
AND, I MEAN, HE'S THE STRONG
HEAD.
DON'T LET ANYONE THINK ANYTHING
DIFFERENT.
>> RIGHT.
>> HE SPEAKS, AND HIS PEOPLE
SPEAK UP AT ATTENTION.
I WANT MY PEOPLE TO DO THE SAY.
>> YEAH, THEY SIT UP IN